go down on the one just like the waters
thought what are we gonna do Jenna
we're on our way to do the Twin Falls
hike so we decided if we get stuck out
here my option of getting coconuts on
trees was to do push-ups for a week and
then be strong enough to go up and get
him but Jenna a better idea
you get gigantic rocks and just throw
them with the coconuts which one do you
guys think is better I kind of think
mine's better but whatever no Fran I J
Grylls and we're here headed to the Twin
Falls I'm Gretta nervous because we're
gonna happen to I'm Abed nervous because
I feel that the crevasse is gonna be
coming up so they're gonna have to pass
it but I know I've experienced in these
types of things you just go and you just
fold the river it's a big crevasse but
we can do it we can do it
only one of the Falls I don't know where
the other ones that we made well I mean
I haven't made over here
patron being bit up we're up to 700 you
can definitely see it it's a huge whoa
Johnny get those bananas wait oh my god
Nana